merci cher laurent sayède ce sera le mot
de la fin en tout cas sur ce sujet
puisque je propose d'en aborder à un
autre on ne parle que de ça depuis
quelques semaines les offensives parfois
virulentes du et mouvements antiracistes
qui notamment souhaitent
que par exemple disparaissent de
l'espace public des personnalités
controversées de notre histoire comme
colbert grand ministre de louis xiv mais
aussi l'inventeur du code noir régissant
les esclavages ou du
général bugeaud l'un des chefs
militaires français qui ont mené la
colonisation de l'algérie dans des
conditions extrêmement brutal c'est la
couverture du figaro magazine
mais c'est aussi l'objet de notre débat
ce soir olivier babeau la question qu'on
se posait c'était pas de savoir s'il
fallait déboulonner les statues celle
est de savoir si face à ce qui apparaît
quand même comme des dérives l'état à
une part de responsabilité je vais vous
donner un exemple dans le figaro
magazine de ce week-end juline weintraub
que les internautes de point de vue
connaissent bien dénonce le l'entrisme
de certains mouvements qu'on appelle
indigéniste au sein de l'université
française
bref elle nous dit l'état pourrait faire
quelque chose pour éviter ces dérives
est-ce que c'est aussi votre avis oui
c'est extrêmement préoccupant ce qui se
passe dans l'université mais alors
l'université c'est en fait pas
totalement l'état je m'explique c'est à
dire que les système d'élection et de
cooptation collégiale qui font que c'est
pas complètement contrôlé en fait de
l'extérieur donc au bout d'un moment
une fois que vous avez certaines
certaines écoles de pensée qui sont
entrés elles peuvent arriver à se
reproduire et un peu se développer de
façon un peu mais métastatique sans
qu'ils aient vraiment de contrôle pour
le coup moi je peux me féliciter la
position du président macron qui a été
extrêmement fermé je crois très très
pertinente c'est l'idée qu'il faut
jamais ouvrir la boîte de pandore sur ce
sujet là si on commence à déboulonner
une statue y aura toujours une raison
pour enlever les suivantes
il y aura toujours une ligne dans
l'oeuvre d'un auteur qui ne plaira pas
nos nouveaux codes et il faut absolument
fermer la porte à ces gens qui
voudraient pas le cas lisez la société
pour au prétexte d'essayer de l'unifier
qui voudraient discriminés pour lutter
contre la discrimination et développer
des injustices pour lutter contre les
injustices
la réponse française traditionnelle
celle de l'universalisme celle qui ne
veut pas essentialiser c'est à dire
donner à des gens uniquement sur leurs
caractéristiques une une qualité ou un
défaut essentialiser bien évidemment sur
la culture de peau qui se refuse
absolument à faire toute distinction de
ce point de vue là ça me paraît
fondamental en revanche qui est
important le problème à mon avis qui est
posée à travers le pseudo succès
médiatique de ce genre de mouvement
c'est en réalité non pas un problème
ethnique à mon avis mais un problème
social et un problème de
d'ascenseur social c'est en fait une
espèce de manifestations dérivés d'une
vraie d'un vrai problème dans la
mobilité sociale et donc et d'un
déterminisme social réel dans notre pays
donc c'est plutôt ça qu'il faut traiter
certainement pas commencé à distribuer
des bons points des vis et des lycées
des statuts et interdire des livres
alors je me demande si nos quatre
invités vont pas être d'accord entre eux
sur ce sujet on va le voir dans un
instant mais bien sûr vous demande aussi
votre avis voici celui de joël velasque
qui a été donné sur lefigaro.fr il y à
quelques quelques heures ces gens
portent atteinte à l'intégrité et à la
sécurité des nation française nous dit
il en parlant de ses militants
antiracistes qui veulent notamment
revisiter notre histoire
il prêche ouvertement la haine
l'affrontement qu'attendent les pouvoirs
publics pour les mettre définitivement
et totalement hors d'état de nuire
c'est d'accord avec cette position ou au
contraire vous n'êtes pas exprimez vous
et je relaierai naturellement vos prises
de position
adrien matou votre votre point de vue
sur ce sujet est ce que par exemple un
homme comme le général bugeaud dont je
disais que il avait eu des méthodes
extrêmement violents dans la
colonisation de l'algérie est ce qu'il
est normal qu'ils continuent à voir des
rues des avenues à son nom aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui on n'aurait peut-être pas
une nouvelle rue nom de général du jour
mais à mon avis ce débat sur le
déboulonnage des statuts le fait de
dénommer les rues est un petit peu
anecdotique en vérité par rapport à la
question du racisme
pourquoi pour aller vite pourquoi pas
contextualiser en mettant un petit texte
dans les cas les plus extrêmes mais on a
vu à l'étude serait complètement
contre-productif
en attendant ça ne puisse pas le débat
sur le racisme en france
à mon avis il ya à la fois des mesures à
prendre en matière de racisme parce
qu'il existe quand même du racisme et
notamment au sein de l'état alors je
n'ai pas dire raciste d'état
j'ai dit racisme peut être au sein de
l'état de la part de certains agents il
faut peut-être se doter de meilleurs
outils pour le pour le repérer
par exemple le testing on peut penser
aussi à la généralisation du cv anonyme
au fait de punir peut-être plus
sévèrement qu'en c'est incontestable
mais il ya aussi ce problème de
l'antiracisme politique et donc une
nouvelle famille de l'antiracisme qui
est complètement opposé à lumière
s'allume et français on a raison de dire
qu'elle se développe beaucoup dans
l'université
alors la liberté académique c'est
extrêmement important
par contre l'état n'a pas forcément
vocation à subventionner des
départements qui je pense notamment au
département de cultural se disent qu'ils
sont donc directement importée des états
unis est-ce qu'il est légitime que la
république française verse des
subventions à des disciplines qui
pressent chaque jour son rejet
à mon avis on pourrait couper de manière
très rapide très efficace très brutal
peut-être les subventions publiques à
ces départements par exemple en norvège
il ya dix ans il y avait eu un
documentaire qui avait montré que le
département de gender studies norvégien
ne reposait sur aucune base scientifique
les norvégiens tout simplement couper
les subventions publiques et enfin
dernier point je pense que l'état
devrait être plus attentifs aux
associations avec lesquelles il
travaille
je prends juste un exemple mais il ya
une association qui s'appelle coexister
qui donne des ateliers dans beaucoup
d'écoles de collèges des lycées sur la
citoyenneté française sur la laïcité le
fondateur de cette association il ya
quelques jours a dit qu'il fallait tuer
libéralisme voilà est-ce que l'état est
légitime à s'associer avec de telles
associations je ne suis pas sûr et je
pense qu'on pourrait attendre c'est là
dessus vous pensez que l'état aura le
courage entre guillemets de s'opposer à
ce qui apparaît quand même comme des
dérives
moi ça me semble très compliqué alors je
pourrais être honnête c'est pas ce
gouvernement là qui doit être tenu pour
responsable de l'état actuel de la
situation parce qu'en réalité ce sont
des dessins climat qui infuse et pas
seulement à l'université parce que c'est
aussi le cadre dans les lycées dans dans
l'éducation nationale de façon générale
tout un climat de
de d'acculturation mais pas dans le sens
où on entend de déculturation
pourrait-on dire général qui fait que
une certaine jeunesse ce sens le droit
d'aller déboulonner des statues d'hommes
qui ont fait la grandeur de la france
avec une forme de chronos centrisme si
j'ose dire vous savez on parle des trn
aux centristes mais il ya aussi le
chrono centrisme c'est à dire qu'on est
incapable de se remettre et c'est quand
même un manque d'intelligence fort et un
manque de recul c'est extrêmement
inquiétant pour une génération de se
mettre dans le contexte de l'époque
en réalité si l'on devait rentrer dans
les standards de 2 comment dire
actuelles imposées par le politiquement
correct c'est tout le monde qu'on
devrait déboulonner je vois qu'une
l'auteur de harry potter a des ennuis
parce qu'elle a dit que seules les
femmes avaient des leurs règles par
exemple pour changer du registre ai pas
parlé d'antiracisme
eh bien je me demande quel homme célèbre
et guay l'on a sur nos statuts dans nos
villes dirait aujourd'hui contraire donc
en réalité il n'ya aucun aucune capacité
à appréhender l'état d'esprit de
l'époque on est incapable d'entendre
moi je rends compte par exemple que
colbert et bien certes ça nous paraît
monstrueux parce qu'il n'est pas revenu
sur sur l' esclavage est néanmoins pour
son époque par le feu
peu de noir il a adouci et d'une
certaine façon les conditions de vie et
c'est reconnu par les historiens des
esclaves
donc tout cela vient quand même d'un
d'un manque d'éducation d'un manque de
culture d'une dune comme d'une éducation
nationale qui dispense des cours
extrêmement orientée et tout cela ce
n'est pas
emmanuel macron qu'il va changer ce pas
d'un coup de baguette magique qui
m'ennuie c'est qu'à mon avis dont on n'a
pas la volonté moi je ne voulais pas
tout à fait là mais les mêmes
conclusions que les débats rgo vous
savez c'est un peu la fable de la
fontaine de là le jeu c'est quoi la
chauve souris et les deux souhaitent je
crois où il dit regardez j'ai dl je suis
oiseau
et puis après il dit il et kylie kylie
sourire bon et c'est un peu ça puisqu'il
a dit on s'opposera à déboulonner les
statues mais ensuite le lendemain matin
y aille a dit oui pourra y avoir des
exceptions donc et puis voilà merci et
je cite de mémoire je suis oiseau voyez
mes ailes
je suis souris vivent les rats sur
twitter vous êtes 86 % à considérer que
entre les statue déboulonnée et les
conférences annulées oui les conférences
annulées ça c'était une allusion
peut-être à la conférence que devait
organiser plus exactement qui devait se
tenir sur le site de l'école de commerce
bien connu audencia sur le l'héritage de
napoléon et la direction d'école a
annulé cette conférence sous prétexte
raisons sanitaires et en fait parce que
vous avez qu à cette polémique autour de
napoléon et qui avait rétabli dans une
certaine mesure l'esclavagé vous êtes 86
7% a considéré que l'état doit répliquer
et puis voici deux points de vue celui
de cécile il nous faut accepter la part
d'ombré de notre histoire qui fait aussi
ce que nous sommes aujourd'hui
déboulonner les statues seigner l'autre
passé or il faut l'expliquer
contextualiser et aider à comprendre
sans pour autant nous renier et puis
dame qui considère que c'est clairement
du révisionnisme je cite son mot il faut
poursuivre pénalement tous les auteurs
de ces dégradations ainsi que tous les
organisateurs
laurence taillade c'est un mot qui
revient beaucoup dans ce débat-là
contextualisations c'est à dire que on
pourrait par exemple expliqué au pied
des statues qui était la personne et et
montrer que le bilan est peut-être
contrastées est ce que ça vous paraît
une une bonne piste à suivre de la part
de l'état je pense que déjà on devrait
instruire les enfants à l'école pour
commencer et à mon avis
l'un des principaux problèmes de l'école
républicaine laïque aujourd'hui c'est
que déjà elle finance en grande partie
l'école privée confessionnelle donc on a
une instruction à deux vitesses une
instruction qui finalement et c'est
gressèque ségrégationniste il ya les
classes sociales qui peuvent fréquenter
l'école l'école privée confessionnelle
c'est essentiellement l'enseignement
catholique qui à ma connaissance préfère
ériger des statues à la sainte vierge
que de déboulonner les statues de nos
grands hommes
oui mais on construit des sociétés sur
la mixité et en l'occurrence quand déjà
on commence à séparer les sociétés dès
la maternelle etc les gens ne se
côtoient pas eh bien ça crée un premier
problème dans la société
l'autre problème de la société c'est le
fondement c'est le fond de l'instruction
qui est donné avant quand vous rentriez
à l'école on vous demander ce que vous
avez envie et ce que vous aviez envie de
devenir maintenant vous demande qui vous
êtes et on vous assigne à cette nouvelle
identité que vous vous défie de dos vous
vous définissez donc c'est l'identité du
quartier
c'est l'identité de la famille d'origine
c'est l'identité de la religion et c'est
comme ça qu'on a complètement fracturé
la nation parce que je rappelle quand
même que la nation elle s'appuie sur
deux choses d'abord l'histoire commune
revendiquer et toute civilisation à des
zones d'ombré n'y a pas que les
occidentaux je vous rappelle quand même
qu'ils ont pratiqué l'esclavagé ils
l'ont bien compris
vous me paraissez parce qu'on arrive à
la fin de la mission de vous répéter ma
question est ce que la
contractualisation c'est une bonne idée
ou pas dans ce cas là il est important
de contextualiser toute l'histoire
humaine
et de rappeler à ceux qui aujourd'hui
sont dans la revendication racialiste
parce que c'est bien ça que eux mêmes
eh bien ils ont contribué un des
systèmes qui étaient des systèmes pas
très glorieux je rappelle que les blancs
ci ont été victimes de l' esclavage et
qu'on n'est pas en train de revendiquer
contre les civilisations arabes qui nous
ont pour certains réduits à l'esclavagé
donc à un moment il faut savoir aussi
être capable d' amnésie pour pouvoir
avancer ensemble parce que le pote de
l'humanité c'est d'avancer ensemble avec
un projet commun merci saint laurent et
c'est vrai que olivier babeau on n'a pas
le temps d'en débattre mais votre
institut s'appelle sapiens jeu pas très
sûr que les sapiens soit très au clair
par rapport aux néandertal acquise en
cas même fait beaucoup de mal mais on ne
vous demande pas de vous des baptisés
c'est promis merci beaucoup à tous les
quatre merci à vous
de nous avoir suivis et ce sera un
bonheur de vous retrouver lundi prochain
d'un point de vue